coupure à nouveau les parties on n'a
quasiment rien raté
on va rappeler vlad et on est bon moment
aucune idée pourquoi pour conduire ce
problème quoi qu'on se laisse remettre
ta caméra on n'a quasiment rien raté un
du coup la juste raté grille de votre
compte de cette fois ici max est plus ou
moins con quoi oui il joue c'est un
auteur un autre système
et c'est bien sûr c'est une décision
correcte de sa part de ne pas répéter ce
que les jouets 3 4 foireux là il a bien
fait de 2006 mais il va faire un iphone
blanc il va jouer ces quatre oui ok to
somme toute évidence et pour jouer ce
4ème 5 d'un côté c'est logique mais de
l'autre côté ça ou vers les positions et
on se demande pour qui les positions
ouvertes et mieux si on peut faire un
truc marrant comme dam des cartes déjà
d'abord il faut voir ce coup puis je
suis pas sûr que c'est un bon coup dans
l'idée c'est de menacer d'emprunts à
sept et perder pièce est une pièce après
tours à huit ans à faire une pièce mais
suivant ce que tu fais à voter dans le
dos se coulant fait en fait parce que ça
peut être quoi le problème avec eux 5
c'est que ça être affublé les cases
blanches oui donc une fois les cases
blanches sont affaiblis c'est sa logique
de mettre les pieds sur les cases
blanches aux 4 je pense pas que ça
marche parce que en boucle juste à tiens
il veut dire que le pion but d'hoarau
dans ces cas là ça va on va faire
cavalier 1,5 et puis on va
dans ce cas là oui ça va nous les noirs
n'ont aucun problème s'il ya quelqu'un
qui a des problèmes ce qu'il faut c'est
que les banques peut-être segal mais je
préfère les noirs un peu surtout il est
bien fait de ne pas échanger le fou sur
jeuxcapt parce que le faux est très
bizarre sur ce cadre il est pas bien
c'est faux c'est quoi donc ok une autre
fois une décision pratique il veut
échanger les pièces pour soulager les
pressions que les noix on obtenu sur les
bois en grumes grâce aux couacs au qatar
n'au aucune cette fois-ci grêce que
n'est pas trop bien là et peut-être ça
va être différent avec cette cadence
voici à dire que c'est royal veut dire
quoi il boucle ou fou et il veut dire
qu'il veut bouffer le il ya toujours
beaucoup aimé pionnat ces rémunérations
je veux faire tourner de la blatte
peut-être pour deux tours de l'arrivée
sur pied d'ici ce voile et des six
bombes tout intérêt à raison d'ailleurs
comme la d6 peut être un bon tour pour
quelques pas tout enfant non mais il est
évident qu'il est noir sont mieux ça
c'est clair
f5 peut-être je pense que 5 ok fois ci
ça paraît très prometteuse tour des
retours de trois tours d'un taux
d'octroi peut-être
ok ok il menace de deux est fou de 2 ok
c'est ce futur ok peut-être info jouer
cavalier 4h fleuve d'eau mais il est
clair que les noirs sont gagnés avec un
point de plus et très mal traités à un
moment donné par échouent alors qu'ils
n'y ont pas joué dans me2 peut-être un
doux et jouer en top 14 s'est il arrêté
de m'écouter
on devait le faire que parce que qu'elle
est là elle est vraiment injuste très
très mal ça risque de devenir plus 3 wim
donc ce qui nous paraît en blitz il est
très important lorsque tu perds une
partie de données par entrer dans les
séries des pertuis
d'arrêter l'hémorragie dont claire
maintenant il va perdre elle va voir à
quel point elle est capable de tenir les
prisons torrent peut-être pas mal
d'heures peut-être pas mal parce que
comme ça ils contrôlent les cases pas
foot fric et ça c'est ça c'est très bien
joué l'idée centrale maintient que
preuve de zèle truc il voit tout de
suite la menace de riom a cohort le
futur pour les banques et aux bornes
grâce au power 4x worms très bien rock
est ok
quoique tu fais ce foutu homos qui il
veut comme les d4 je soutiens ce que
plus ou moins la même chose ok fougeux
3g à 6 5 mais il va chercher plus que ça
bien sûr un outil que si ce conte pour
les bois contre 40 plus pour le noir et
les noirs son grain de récits c'est très
intéressant avec les détours bassiste
russie souhaite de réussir ce gain parce
que tours sans qu'ils aient encore que
les 10 4-6 sagan dessus car si c'était
plus fort demain sur l'effet retour et 6
échecs mais bon ça doit suffire quand
même ça suffit mais les bois on ne peut
pas dire que les noirs les bois non pas
d un éventuel moi ici m arrive aux ados
comment dire à faire le cercle autour de
biologie paroisse de 3 que les seconds
rôles qui est bien sûr ce foutiyou même
il faut avoir montré les techniques tels
se faire rage 6,3 g 5 qu'élever je crois
comme d'habitude de mark streit ça très
concrètement vue aux déplacés lecavalier
et échanger le pion de 3 pour le pion
doit être sérieux sans cacher la non
abonnés aux cinq mètres qu'à attendre à
voir quand les 4 alors que l'école
escapade au sirop à 4 tours jeu 4 est
une pure bonheur mais je suis pas sûr
qu'ils ont tous à sainté bien joué trois
fois que le 12 octobre en colère à 2,7
c'est plus précisément
sur les 2,8 pourrait aussi se coller de
oui bon ok mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ça c'est assez bordélique oui parce que
le roux alward un coût est devenu pas
trop bien montpeloux convalescents ou
comme les u6 à genève a fait retour j'ai
cinq au lieu de f5 pour sa greffe cinq
échecs c'est pas dur à dire ok au f4 il
faut activer dont je dois je paroisse un
sens ok et les fous tout cas je crois
que carew gardien placé veille ce cas
car il ya des trucs avec il ya des idées
avec la perpet ou pourquoi quand les
quatre à huit tours à sept tours à huit
tours à cette élite pouvait se sauver je
pense à dire waouh qui vivent ça c'était
impressionnant dans d'incroyables il est
joué c'est tout ce que je me parler
d'éco ça ce très beau c'est quoi qui est
en prend trois points 4 nuls
ivey retour machin mais c'est nul quand
même nom tourache mitschek
pour h m cheikh ce nul bon ok ce nouveau
bouquet tour à lui réfuté saignant sur
la suite tour g8 ont évoqué les
opérations au dos au flash ça c'était
impressionnant
non mais c'est insupportable lavallière
qu'à quatre collèges aussi ça m'a choqué
peut-être d'ailleurs tous ramer terrasse
est ça a été à ce qu'ils ont mais juge
me demande si je n'ai pas pu le df 5
fait retour g5 tu vois tiens ce mois ce
qui a commencé avec ce cas parce que là
jamais un foyer un cordon se mange non
mais ça coûte cher parce que ça nous
aurait permis de revenir à trois points
on ne peut pas se permettre avec les
avec maxime de laisser passer des
opportunités
ok tu essaies m'acharne de 5 je pense
que les choucas et ou plusieurs parties
comme ça de jeunes y compris concerné
que morale est ici prend pas avec je
pense que il prenait pas avec le
cavalier primé avec le prix en euros il
est possible que je me trompe
j'aimerais réaliser ça mais je pense que
si les noirs jouent précieusement c'est
égal
oui tu vas faire jordan des deux caves à
nice 2-2 food ou d'amodio que vous les
d4 d'un bouche que voulait 5 égalité
donc maintenant tout va vite est
intéressant mais si le fossé d'euros 2,4
c'est être un peu trop symétrique lablad
non oui mais tu vois il a des problèmes
avec eux quatre donc il essaie un peu
partout
là maintenant au moins les noirs comme
quoi joue et il faut d'autres 2 comme
les décadents presque fou de katell que
deux fous je souhaite intermédiaire
oncle à au moins un que je donc mais les
noirs gloire je fous 9,5 avec les
défauts au kac ici que les c4 comme les
deux cadres marché ça y est les noirs
égalisait pascal heidecker il est
possible que fout de quatre voies
égaliser aussi d'air moi je préfère que
vale avec pourquoi faut aussi ça
insupportable on faut ici ça par contre
c'est pas trop quelle impression
complètement symétrique
mais les bons en termes de plus - c'est
que grâce au couple suisse gibbs
peut-être quand même les 2 1 il peut
utiliser quand même plus haut les bornes
en voyant pions sur f3 pour gagner un
temps au quai sarrail relate c'est
complètement symétrique et toujours les
boulons avec un temps de plus
complètement complètement ce que veut
dire que ok ça doit être égal quand même
parce que les pressions mais bien
croquer normalement dans les pressions
breux qui entendent 1000 x - nanterre -
important que de l'opposition vient
d'ailleurs offrir une aspiration comme
cavalier 7%
j'aime bien ok il veut il veut dire que
qu'est ce que tu as dit que je serais
peut-être courir mais moi je vais pas
pouvoir sept mois gérer ferreux comme
les dossiers sociaux mais c'est affreux
ok maintenant je pense qu'il était le
temps de jeu à 9,5 de nouveau avec
l'idée que vos livres 4 phoques à la
fourrure toi ok dans ce cas là ok si tu
répètes peut-être il faut répéter
jusqu'à défendre mais j'aime pas sa
décision de répéter jusqu'à 22 premiers
coups un peu trop long un peu trop long
quand même un moment donné il faut
arrêter ça quand tu t'interroges
dramatiser tiens les différences par
exemple si tu joue cavalier 5e volée aux
six cavaliers 3 toujours symétriquement
cavale et je sens que les banques
avaient jusqu'au menu comme anecdote je
suppose que après que voulait aussi s'il
va prendre avec le pion à b3 ouais c'est
l'histoire juste c'est juste l'histoire
faux de faire un coup
ok hélas comme quoi deux fois plus de
temps donc il joue sur le temps je pense
qu'elle va le voir de plus en plus
souvent dans ce match qui ô marx va
viser les points de vue mais qu'est ce
que tu veux faire avec l'émergence tu
prends ça sont en hausse ici va te
reprendre avec la gare et tu peux faire
et ce qui est ma part je pense que pour
l'instant tu peux rien faire tout ce que
tu peux faire c'est de bouger très vite
garder les pièces sur l'échiquier c'est
tout ce que tu peux faire pour vous
c'est quoi des fois ce 3 qui est
toujours pas trop db quoi que je fais je
peux faire face' ce tueur je m'en fiche
que réussit ce feu mais bon ça laisse
réfléchir gris tchouk sarrès réfléchir
une vie riche ou que je sais c'est
consolider pour l'instant je pense qu'il
peut y avoir un piège cas chez nous pas
vraiment quand lucie cela maintenant à
il veut bouffer avec la dame préférez
toujours de beaux frères
le pion mais je sais pas non mesdames et
du pratique c'est parce que tu attaques
3 et attaques des quatre situe peut
menacer fou prend des quatre m'ont l'a
pas vraiment ce qui a le fourrage 3 qui
cloue voyait toujours franson en plus
bientôt ira passer du temps pour pouvoir
calculer le les conséquences de telles
opérations
peut-être parce que même si c'est une
menace dames 4e r3 tu de ta pas
d'enlever à faire leur a peut-être élevé
au collet de quatre maintenant fou c'est
ce que va lire trois écoles et de deux
anneaux moment roy bouche que les deux
fours de st ok je d'avocate
c'est ça ce qu'il veut sur d'un méga je
ferais sujet 2 dans le cadre d'un de
quatre fautes de kadhafou de cinq fauves
de foule où se trouvaient des raisons
oui ok il veut faire gaffe ou jeu de
dames système est ok peut-être une
petite torture comme il faut trois etc
ça continue faut trois roches rythme
cette fouille et sans toit rouge dit ok
ok pour si jamais pour que le pilotage
d'un f4 maintenant oui oui pourquoi pas
je voudrais évoquer ils pressent presse
il prêt sur le point de presse sur le
positionnement toujours rien de suspect
mais les murs
il faut absolument la gagner ça lave la
tour nous à près d'1 9 4e volet le 5 mai
ya fourche 3e qui commence parfois trois
essais de reverte maintenant maintenant
que tuteur barricades maintenant adamo
cas mais pourquoi cette dame au qatar
bien son nom mais jordan me cassait 3,5
et alors d'annoncer cette raison
or qu ils souffrent souvent c'est pas
optimisme non mesdames c'est cette vie
un jour et tout est cloué ces mêmes dur
de trouver un bon coup la police pour
les noirs le chili est convoqué et les
et les rockets pour fouiller cinq
joueurs wii qui il n'est pas vraiment ok
mais il voit rien d'autre n'est pas ok
est ce que cette position n'est blanc
table contraintes et le tacticien comme
max est jamais très agréable mais
d'ailleurs peut-être au lieu s'il est un
bon moment donné il peut jouer 4 rue de
chou si la dame bouche de bouille
battant mais la maxime est en train de
tourner ce qu on emporte qui aurait pris
à sa place ok je suis prêt à manger 7
c'est juste qu'à un moment donné la
finale de fous où elle peut réagir et
oui même si je pense que faire re de
vlad avec l'idée sur dame prend prise à
mahfoud et 4 encore non mais peut-être
ait pu reprendre à jouer avec le terroir
d'euros de trois fois ce que je pensais
tu coureuse de là c'est peut-être le
coup je pense qu'être catholique ou ici
f4 à nous y adapter
je deviens de plus en plus ridicule
mouais et auquel voir des trois as roi
des trolls et sur qui on prend vous
prends et je vends qui six fois justice
maintenant fouet f4f je refuse c'est
hélas il faut calculer poule 4 me si les
boues un viol gagner ils doivent jouer
christian bouquet ce qu le foot mais
qu'est ce que je fais je vous gagnez ou
quoi non je ne peux plus gagner
non mais ça ne peut pas gagner les
quatre énoncé si on bouge pas comme ça
c'était très bizarre
il devrait jouer au qatar je vous
souhaite pour compliquer dupont tient
peut-être qu'ils voulaient pas risquer
hussien ok mais hélas moins quatre
camions
voeckler est encore les bullet on n'est
même pas une image rade ailleurs h4
presque sûr que c'est nul jusqu'à ce
cadre il faut simplifier la pause
ok vous devez trouver ici si tu portais
reste évasif ouest tout ce que tu veux
ton ta vie je te donne cinq ports tu vas
rien tu vas pouvoir rien faire 1
déjà le roi va jamais passé mais même
s'il passe je tiens monde fou sur 2,8 et
loisirs attends attends mais ça m'a
l'air d'être assez soupçonnant ce que
fait gris tout nous allons évoquer tant
que relais à ses coûts et les as écouté
vos données précises permettant de
partir maintenant
ok mais tu pourras jamais passé avec me
voir que sait-on jamais souvent d'hôtel
finale sur nous mêmes avec ampli en
double tout simplement parce que leur
poste et les bois aussi en appui sur la
cage noire week end je saisis sans
problème ça est ok on n'était pas loin
non d'ailleurs grichka montré des bonnes
herbes salées max hoff
il faut recoller vlad londres toujours
alors ok faut 12 may cry photo max
souvent max est fidèle à ses habitudes
oui s'il a commencé de jeu une
souveraineté le continuer pourquoi petit
chou qui t'appelle pas pendant la pause
ben je pense qu elle ait rien demandé
mais j'ai rien de moi j'ai rien à dire
je pense que max a pu appeler y tiennent
d'ailleurs que vale a trop assez
intéressant non je pense pas en fait pas
mal de témoins qui en fait trop tendu
pour parler avec qui que ce soit tiens
moi je pensais qu'il l'idée était de
mettre le cabinet sur hbo 5 mais ce
n'est pas ce produit
j'aime bien ce concept a fait ça c'est
une pression achi typique pour pour le
système monde
les noirs donc spicules sur les des deux
bouffées sur trois est bouffé sur 10 4
me paraît que ça va pas arriver cette
fois ci les bords vieux je reçois comme
5 soit koné 55 hockey bien joué et bien
joué
ok je pense que historique mois et n'y a
jamais carrière scatman anglade
il n'a jamais obtenu une position aussi
bien que cette fois ci dans le système
au monde
jeu à chaque fois c'était moins bien que
maintenant pour moi non mais j'ai
l'impression que le match est en train
de s'équilibrer voire même d'être
légèrement al'avantage de max pour le
moment sauf que les rites pas de but et
ça ça n'arrive pas à but et il n'a pas
débuté d'ailleurs baby peut-être 10.10
partis flamands
non mais il ne put pas la fin du monde
comme qui ont apparu comme emmener le
bus tout y est mais il a buté que la
deuxième non pas peut-être réputé que
sur une partie de hockey ce que je
referai le très bon ok je pense que les
noirs doivent être comme quoi un petit
peu mieux peut-être nettement mieux je
sais pas s'il faut des trois il ya cinq
aurait donc qui est ce qu'il faut faire
je ne sais pas ce que j'aime et
spécialiste de ce type de pose ok comme
il est là je préfère à par rapport aux 2
3 face aux questions des quatre fers au
feu décodeur que je remets ya quelques
mois mais ça c'est facile à voir ces
mêmes banques et siège non en fait c'est
pareil paris a maintenant sortir
peut-être il veut libérer le pion bruit
pour pouvoir pousser bo5 bécade non mais
comment tu protèges d'ambert ouais mais
bon je sais moi j'ai un mec primaire je
joue d'un bug tamek à l'ancienne revoilà
parce que sur une cinquième fois
c'est pas la fin du monde à cause de
quatre mais quand même 3 il faut
calculer des syndicats quand même à ma
non non non non pas le câble est sûre on
voit trop vite se déplacer sur ce simple
ça aussi donc nous quoi sur moi j'ai
reçu 2,3 votre ça c'est sûr pour du bien
pour dimanche et le fou du roi
mais peut-être car les 2/3 intéressant
avec les décors et serein parce que
cavaliers detroit qui veut coller ce
sens que si brice éventuellement non de
trois comme les boucs et messieurs ce
soupçon comme les deux trois jours
tu me poses des questions oui pose des
questions oui donc juste il doit faire
ça un peu plus rapidement
il va pas faire briller ça c'est sûr je
pense qu'il va jouer quelque chose comme
dans le dossier déjà sa dame n'est pas
trop bien passé sur 1,5 je pense que
vaut mieux qu'il est là quelque part sur
cette tête vers fois ci sera j'essaie
tour h ou 8 h 5 h 4 est ce qu'il doit
faire d'un peu 3
non parce que après dans votre eau abris
et des trucs fous des quatre et six
affaires de détroit nombre non me fous
de 4 et au riboul feu dans votre bureau
de 4 je vois pas comment serait il à l
agence pour trouver le truc
d'ailleurs ça c'était un choix était le
doyen
l'idée c'est qu'à presser prendre b4 que
les des cadres ya pas qu on laisse la
cause de tous je vais montrer un cd
quartier prend des quatre menaces le fou
si le fou sans vent par le cavalier sur
cavaliers c'est un tour pensait à tort
français car l épreuve donc content a
dit max a commencé de dominer et donc de
nouveau à l'imposition mêmes of stew je
parle de nous avec alex tanguay dont
j'ai une question pour toi est ce que tu
aimes les positions dominantes
[Rires]
taïaut déjà quelqu'un qui t'a dit le
contraire oui et toi mais oui on fera
than life plus tard
détriment un moment donné j'ai un foutu
un final aussi horrible que cela compte
yannick mais bien sûr les fumeurs les
horribles où air hockey par contre que
des talibans peuvent à un moment donné
spéculer avec des idées comme x 6 x 2
faut bosser tout est ok je pense qu'avec
g4g 3 elle a un peu amélioré sa pause
mais elle doit être futur où elle doit
être foutu malgré les foudres couler
reposer mahler mais pas il faut jouer au
poker un peu passées au noir de joueurs
phocéens
d'ailleurs je pense que max a déconné
adjoint fouet fuite c'était beaucoup
plus technique que je ne sache pas que
tient dirait quelqu'un dans le chatt
post key qui dit vive la préfère jouer
avec 2 da camara pas le diable de les
blagues de austin powers par rapport à
celui sur mobile usa et qui peut je
rappelle plus de cette blague mais fait
à temps sur la preuve de 20 c'est elle à
la blague est le plus génial de pourtant
j'ai vu ce film tu as une quinzaine de
fois tu dois refaire ok donc l'évolution
de toujours horrible pour les doigts
mais mais mais mais je garde l'espoir 5
4 1 er que les trois roues et six
cavaliers 4 et peut-être à nous sauver
comme tous les cas maurice à 85,6 bien
sûr mais dans tous les cas quand même
assez mauvaise technique de la part de
max parce qu à la place de foot à 5 pour
fixer le pion au bout 3 était beaucoup
plus haut a été beaucoup plus technique
les mots de marc webb si juste pour bien
sûr aux accessoires saint caprais
d'ailleurs ça rend le cavalier en bio
pas trop bien le commander sur deux sets
parce que comme quoi les par quatre mais
plutôt que ça va pas durer mais j'ai
voué aux agf
de l'autre côté pourquoi pas peut-être
ça va je sais pas où vous allez à ça
c'est un bon
et pourquoi pas ramener le roi sur f6 je
comprends rien en fait là par contre là
ça a été moins à la fête et moi je
revois je sais que vous les retrouverez
fils et fois six fosses et 8 après ce
bon ok je comprends ce que tu veux
charger roi sept cavaliers j'ai trois
rois et 6 x 6 et 8 français cinq et f5
et f5 est visé pour l'éternité
quoique peut-être fois ou à fouras si ce
même pas obligatoire parce que france 3
c'est bon aussi pour toi tu menace
croissante du sud a elle complique les
choses fausses et que les boucistes nous
on est là bien là la bataille des 5 et 6
il a bien fait et au cavalier six
cavaliers des cinq même chose
elle l a bien fait cavaler je crois
plutôt qu'un faux cavaliers 2,5
maintenant et si fou de 5 à 2,5 en
histoire aussi ce que ce soit dont je
sais pas mais je fais aussi kg 4 échecs
oui mais le cavalier et vos voix ici
soupire le cavalier vise 5 et
contrôleurs 5 qui affichait cinq échecs
5e se croit beau fou dit si tu me
proposes quoi je te préviens je suis
d'accord non mais c'est pas très bien
vous nécessite pas un poireau a g6 sas
qui auront va voir maintenant c'est
sûrement sont fixés vlad
je sais d'où son nom ça ça reste
toujours à une question
trois chiens de choses il doit trouver
que tous ces rouages 5 et 26 quoi
l'aider h 3o f donne mon nom ça un
mouvement mais c'est bien ça pour nous
ok là c'est vous
cet abandon
ok + moi ok mais les la tendance a été
telle la tendance à de tels jeux là vous
ça fait plusieurs parties de jacques
namont a fini par buter vlaar ok + 3 l
heure donc tient la sicilienne et b3 ce
que je joue aussi
ok moi aussi j'ai réfléchi 6 heures
photo dr les saucisses les baisses de
cesse dès que voler de 4600 les baies de
trucs mais si images pour ce soir mais
généralement là je fais ces quatre en
fait après ce 4e course et que les jeux
auxquels à pioncer en fonction et d 4d 4
c'était ici que voler des 4 x 4 échecs
donc c'est des petits regrets mais tu
peux te vois les épiciers c'est un peu
trop fini un cocon oui j'ai pas bouffer
sur des quatre bureaux attendre que lé
bout en bout tu sais je vais te
surprendre je vais te surprendre
tu as joué déjà ses propositions quelque
chose qui ressemble tu sais comme moi
qui ne m'a pas surpris de nous tous non
maîtrise et contre qui compte 1,1 bruel
nant contre vaste hasek fait nul assez
facile avec quelques couleurs les blancs
mais je pense tu évoques taceq presque
sûr en fait je vous ai dit peut-être
mille fois déjà que je toujours adoré
les deux joué avec le coeur mausolée
donc je peux pas encore critiqué les
positions noir parce que j'adore les
peler les pions meneuse l'est je viens
le noir tient ses 4 si tu dois
absolument gagner peut-être la décision
d'inclure buzzer mais bon des 4 à 6 des
quatre que les 4 x 7,5 rue ça se
comprend donc alors il va pas fuir des
quatre peut-être me vois jouer je sais
ce qui va sûrement égaliser
bon ça jouer quoi là je ne sais pas
qu'est ce que je fais où je 4 pourquoi
pas aux caisses bien sûr les noirs ne
sont pas moins bien d'ailleurs le faut
sur bordeaux comme quoi on n'est pas
mauvais mais il n'est pas tout non plus
à cause d'une blessure square et c'est
pour ça que je connais bien mecha et
dessins je pensais que c'était vous qui
allez faire et et il va liquider il va
reprendre du fou il va faire peut-être
tour c'est un kiff des tours c4 ok tu
fantasmes comme je suis choqué plus
maintenant
dans le beh si j'aime bien le coup parce
que ça pose une question directe au
québec
et qu'est ce que tu vas faire je veux
jouer tous réduits
je défends une foule si jamais qu'est ce
que tu as peut-être un clivage le fou 4
alors il parle avec cette action entre
nos nations quand il fait ce coup qu'est
ce que tu as non j'ai lu ni vraiment
comme ça ou c'est toi seulement c'est
moi c'est toi c'était pour voir
c'est ce que le mec tu menaces au
passage oui justement je connais max
trop bien sûr bien sûr il faut aux
quatre là maintenant ok si d'un mercato
d'ailleurs il peut y avoir un moment
donné un truc avec fou prend h cette
dame ces deux dames français 5
ok mais là s'il faut acheter 305 et d'un
proche de 4 ok la magouille et la
magouille est d'ailleurs c'est la
première fois que la magouille est dans
le sens propre du terme est ok et
l'ajout de gagner 1 billion hockey
serait cool qui gagne il revient à deux
points et
tu as peur d'avaler je sens que ça tient
dans le 4 5
ouah ouah il est vrai les chaud patate
aujourd'hui pas parce que vous l'avez
vous postulez vous savez rapidement mais
dans ce cas tu rêves sans accident
majeur est de retour h lui dit mais là
quand même pas mal de chansons ok je
connais pas l'évolution du truc mais une
chose je sais qu'il va gagner une pièce
ça se sache je sais mais c'est du vol
cette partie a par contre c'est pas les
fans de trucs là parce que dans bouge
roi je sais qu'il faut que cet encours
est donc la faute se continue et en plus
j'avais cette fois ci cette fois 6 avril
qui est nettement moins bien longtemps
non mais il n'avait pas vu sa flamme
fera recette bien sûr les panneaux j'ai
jamais dis que j'ai jamais dit que m
mais s'il aime bien sorti au niveau de
la rapidité de ses réactions
ok je suppose qu'il doit être gagnant -
avec un voile c'est assez chiant ce type
de pose le hockey normalement tu veux
jouer tous f18 même en connaissant max
lui qu il veut quelque chose mais
peut-être des recettes avec les
hurricanes
c'est chiant aux dons quoique peut-être
se faire juste dams et 6 à 5
ok pour que la banque contrôle plus
aussi eu six comme quoi des gages contre
le plus attendu va qu'on peut pas
commencer par h quatre échecs rhin
dames 2 voir ici un dame saint lô plutôt
dense et un appui et 80 voire quatre
quoi d'autre bien sûr il n'a pas vu
quelque chose
bien sûr il a sûrement vous pouvez h
cadre-là il a joué cinq truites mf4 va
je vais essayer de m'en prendre à toi
quoi cette dame ces deux maintenant dans
le dos on voit si ce tour c'est en
dessous de 4 que sa voix je peux jouer
même cavalier 4,5 au lieu de nous croire
à nos collègues de quatre morceaux
programme ready cash par exemple à
l'antique attentes watts dans machete
tour 5 watches mouvements n'ont
peut-être qu'il y ait des cas dans
machete machin tour saint alphonse et
cinq entreprises
tout est en prise la ddt moi je sais pas
qu'est ce que tu vois je vois rien après
tout c'est un faux débat
donc ceci est au bout de l non j'adore
le foot et catch fait d'un me 4 ou là ok
d'autotours x historique de 1 rim que
sacrifie la dame sochaux paris terme de
cette partie et reaper madame irma
mais max il n'a pas fait n'importe quoi
on bien sûr n'importe quoi mais ok mais
c'est pour nous le spectateur ses marins
en plus le reste de la partie doit jouer
sur
sur deux secondes facebook et youtube
bien sûr parce qu'il a plus d' attaque
c'est plutôt madame enjeux cratère jose
mais ça n'en prend pas en fait c'est ce
qui s'est passé fin
non non non seule chose qu'il n'a pas
trouvé les meilleurs coups je pense que
l'airé dieu peut être bouffé sûr je cède
quelque part parce que ça n'a pas marché
ce que la faute au quai d'honneur au
plus 4 m non mais je suis révoltée par
cette partie valdes
tiens regarde un changement tectoniques
au niveau de choix de youtube d'un coup
que les choux café aux 4 pour la
première fois dans ce mois mais est-ce
que je pense qu'on va avoir une âge
d'orb dans ce match ou pas
bk roi quelle innovation vient juste de
ne rien voir un match de basket mais il
a juste d'un pion non écoute et je sais
très bien même si je connais les
réponses je veux pas le dire n'ont pas
mais je sais pas si tu connais ou pas
quelque part tu connais tu peux rien
nous dire ces préparations secrète grand
chose
ok les défauts soeur ou ce sac dans ce
cercle rue qui vous prend des six
d'impro des cages des sisters secrétaire
fo 7 ou 8 pas bon il est pas bien dru ok
il faut à 3 n'est pas trop bien ça c'est
sûr mais peut-être je sais pas quel
point elle est mauvaise c'est quoi ça se
resserre autour de huit fils que vous
les 4 as trop beau pour être vrai mon
jeu a ok c'est ce qu'il veut dans le
cercle les six courageux c'est dommage
trop assisterait filles et fils des
marchés ce matin qui attends je vais
montrer c'est pas trop beau ça pourrait
trouver un as maté sur aff sisters point
est fils d'un métier mais c'est pas
possible
hyde bytes mais bien sûr au lieu de
achetiez s'il faut faire elle ça et là
je sais pas à 5-5 jaj dame je trouve un
bref les tours et fils qui vient diplôme
après celle d'un bon genre sur h5 à tout
moment tu veux faire cavalier prend
prise d'alger trois rois bougeait
toujours profiter your adam g 8
ouais tiens d'ado ans et d'un ok ok il
view ok damas trois à cinq pour que
cornet ça que je lâche dans le froid
comme je suis même et en plus il en
riant pion à ils menacent aussi b6 et
sur dame prend à 8 tours fou bessette
avec le match ouah ok h5 d'un jeu 3 et 6
d'un 9 5 cibles d'un bo5 peut être
élevée au continuer mais mes langues
coliques mois contre son camp mais si ça
marche c'est trop beau pour être vrai
nom c'est trop beau pour être vrai il
menace que valait 1 5 ce qui aurait
assez sinister dame 5%
parce que je vois pas d'autres coûts qui
craignent à terme aussi pur beau ça
c'est ça marche comment est-ce qu'on
peut sauver saab la dares entoure ce un
salaire être assez fort c'est en fait
ok après tour seul peut-être bray six
tours suite au sommet du g8 dans le bois
ne cherche tout simplement à ton tour d
un à elle veut tout rafler tout en brie
sistership trois fuites auraient fui 3e
set de hrw 8 rouages six tours achoui 3e
set je sais pas si ça gagne ou pas
qui va faire tous réfutent ces sur ok au
moins il y perd pas oui donc soit ils
gagnent soit plo à n'a pas le talent de
chevet d'un jeu 5 donc d'argent cinq
chèques de 5 twh les trois jeux suivants
6 4 footon oui quel côté se roi où arôme
ça ce n'est pas la partie du jour à
savenès est d'alger 5 matin par able
danger cinq prises prises et matt a donc
ça c'était quelque chose
tiendrez-vous et s'est mis à jouer long
de schiste ni avec l'autre
ça c'est être au grade non ça c'était
quelque chose mais ça c'était quelque
chose
ok au qatar ici c'est l'un des coups
principal local food 5 avec les 2 3 et 4
je suis un peu abasourdi par la part la
partie précédente
dans miel tout étoile par rapport à la
partie prétendants qui suppose parce que
wickens afrique
ça frémit chatel et en cadence de 3,3
points sauf qu'il est possible qu il
connaissait quelque chose ou un ouais ça
m'étonnerait quand même que le
connaissait les derniers cédric pineau
non mais c'était vraiment too much
c'était vraiment un match de hockey
entre les méthodes dites moi qu'est ce
que t'es réjoui m je pense que le plus
apprécié colère cinq noms je sais pas la
partie précédente m'a mis un gros coup
au moral en fait c'est trop pour moi qui
ai payé rappelant des boulettes encore
c'était assez violent
c'était booth
c'était violent
vous êtes ça chauffait d'un coup ça se
chauffer d'un coup et gravement d'heure
et la donne est un pion pour une
compensation
là maintenant et offrira 5 après je sens
que 4 et je sais pas qu'est ce que ça
donne ah oui les préféré jouer jusqu'au
soir ok c'est plus ou moins n'importe
quoi je pense - ok il veut jouer actifs
quoi mais revenons soudry soutenant
toujours évident qu il ait récemment qu'
il s'est rajeuni d'un coup et d'un coup
il est au lieu de combien de 34 à mêler
de ville presque 34 ans de l'est devenu
comme quoi je bois 18 mois mais
grandement tard et enfin il joue jamais
comme ça c est notamment prévu que je
consomme
sauf que cette fois ci c'est plus ou
moins n'importe quoi ça a été plus ou
moins n'importe quoi je pense moyens
mais ok il est vrai que il est facile de
jouer de tous noirs ici ok ici c'est 3,4
bien sûr sitôt bandama cinq échecs donc
bien sûr dans ce sens là maintenant elle
voulut il faut viser ok il est en cavale
et de cette nuit s'il faut beau 5 turbo
ide et simon née l'idée de devenir fou
de petits rock menacera [ __ ] en bessin
que ça va avec les blancs faut pas
paniquer la balade
non bien sûr les boissons bien mais bien
sûr juste en fait je pense que ce n'est
qu'une solution une solution pratique de
la part de riches à 9 heures comme quoi
objectivement les besoins peut-être
mieux mais j'ai un job facile
tout est donc en place en quelques
sortes il joue sa peau au style de ce
monde vers serment et maxime il joue
tout le temps comme ça pas tout le temps
mais très très souvent mais sauf que
cette fois ci je suis pas sûr qu
objectivement apparence et peut-être
quatre noms tiens c'est 4 et puis f4 a
provoqué une lutte et je suppose ce bo3
rose framboise f4 qui gagnent donc je
suis et la maintenance boutroy bois bien
sûr si jamais qui rejoint f1 javani
détroit
oui mais le cavalier assises que voulez
vous quand tu sais ce que formule 1
n'était hk tâche sans du coup avec le
fou sur je sais qu'elle est toujours dur
de deux fermes ou non c'est maintenant
maintenant si j'aime bien le noir du nom
et des trois dates des deux états non
non je compris compris ce qu'on paie en
fait j'ai dit n'importe quoi que p 3c
dans le dos d'un des deux rois de
dolbeau dr aboya faut bouger et tu crois
que ça oui je vois pas grand chose doit
aucun tir au hockey il est un peu
nouveau tête qui réalisent des trois
noms premier à occuper tir haut qui lui
au jeu que voulez-vous cisco les accable
ok il faut bouchti reculé de 6 en fait
ok c'est intéressant ce que grichka faux
sauf qu'il devait faire tout ça plus
rapidement à quoi est ce qu'un vestige
pas sarthe b3 que pure non tu peux c'est
est dans le style de max en plus eux oui
ou un copain denis cdc dans le style
demeure b3 tu donnes la qualité mais
objective moi je sais pas à quel point
ce four b3 fou prendre d'emprunt que
vous les décès d'un des huit thèmes
aussi les fouilles butoir burqa les deux
sets pour revenir en des huit tf6 avec
la dame
oui ok j'ai une qualité oui qu'il ait
décidé ça à faire ça un peu plus tard et
d'ailleurs forcé les bandes de jouer
quelque chose comme dans le dos fo prend
tout reprendre et la tour sur un est
moins bien placé que la dame au hockey
dans le vide quand même au ghana les
mêmes en simple dames m6 peut s'enlever
efe juste attendre donc peut-être le
vois pas jouer même si ça leur
maintenant non mais ça a été une bonne
décision de ta part et de la part de max
qui viennent je dois y défier la callas
pour un nomade au camp est de simplifier
la tâche quoi de voir le jour facile ok
maintenant je sais pas maintenant il
faut peut-être france 3 comme un gamin
four 3 avec les uns d'amesys
comment peut-être d'investissement
2,5 si on prend le relais ou quatre mois
c'est terrible tout ça quand moquer
c'est très désagréable
d'ailleurs je pense que tête 5
maintenant si on prend des 6es la torah
8 en l'air mais y aura le camélidé aussi
aux cavaliers a l'air aussi sûr de toi
ok me prépare au évoqué au moins née là
ouvrir longue de kaloum pour sa tour au
moins quelque chose maroc et il est
assez moi je pense non de chez moi fier
de ça je pense quoi qui où ce qu'est ce
que je comprends que tu en prends des
six quand même et on prend 2,6 dans le
film et cavaliers ou cinq cavaliers 5e
hockey dans ce que quatre cavaliers 4
ouais ouais possible possible nos monts
quand le 5
alors peut-être pas dans des six à quand
le 5ème cinq mecs d'accord mais
peut-être cavaliers c'est si sa cavale
et c6 quelque chose comme je pas tour 6
si l'enfant m 5 7 rue principale comme
les décisions il faut une il faut
bloquer l'accès à cette case où que vous
les goûts et c'est quoi le matériel deux
pions pour la qualité widgets au talent
pur autant qu'avant de cette dame trois
ans kenji catch concis dames 3 voire
bouge que voler le cas trois tours deux
hotyat world
il est réussi peut-être douille dribbler
pour ce 3 tient sage preuve l'accord les
deux cavaliers eu de brefs six cavaliers
trois blessés et je comprends rien n'est
pas obligé de bouffer tous 8 h 3
d'hambourg bien sûr h3 d'abord roi elle
sert qu'à l'e3 c'est vrai
il faut pas pourquoi ils à tours le pire
ne trop dangereux ce qui fait réellement
le pari sigrist uk touré site on se doit
d'un match solide
donc il doit peut-être à 3 oui peut-être
à 3 même la machouillette dreux 2 il
veut jouer le jeu pour perpète
mais il va perdre des voix qu'un set
faut deux d'un no 2 aura que deux dames
39.4 je pense non les décès dans la
société aux artistes de cette fraude et
7 nuls par pépé parce que c'est clair
que celui hockey décisions pratiques
parler d'eux non c'est parti et extra
lander excellent très très haut niveau
très très haut niveau en estimant hockey
bien sûr c'est nul me mais pourquoi elle
a pris de plus on y vit il faut quoi ok
ce pub est quand même mais dans mon cas
car c'est plus possible
ok ça va ternir comme mais il est mis et
les terminaux de riches ou non mais
qu'est-ce désespérant et il faut quand
même dire que ça a été une partie du
très haut niveau un peu critiqué les
décisions de monsieur était pointe de ce
prime le parti tient qui rit jaune je
laisse iroquois gros line systèmes noms
burlesques est ce normal mais c'est will
kill aient joué avec le noir même et il
joue cinq équipes landaises fidem veille
connais bien mais n'a pas joué sa seule
fois avec loin c'est pas grave non gelée
chine comme aux non et c'est affreux
grâce vient de se passer pour nous on
réussit pas à buter
bon maire
ok je comprends bien sûr et je veux pas
mettre du sel sur vos blessures comme
indiens russes
mais pour l'instant très sûr je me eux
antonio n'ont pour l'instant très chic
jeu mais eux
donc c'est une seule consolation quoi
pour ceux qui enfants pour tout le monde
sauf moi quoi ok écoutez je connais pas
les détails de tout ça parce que qu'est
sebeyran bien voir c'est pas mon truc
mais il est vrai que les deux ont joué
pour un parti avec à côté de ben oui
maigrichon que quand même et les joueurs
ça pour une fois avec le noircir enfin
pas mal de fois et à ma connaissance est
vrai mais là je me ferais sauf que
peut-être et les faits sa dalle est
parti d'un prix moi c'est possible ici
je suppose que les réactions c'est faux
trop apprécié ce que les trois avec les
décors les deux cinquièmes au moins ce
que je vais faire
ok ville est maintenant il va faire que
l'histoire une fois les bois n'arrive à
m le cavaly sur 2,5 et rubans b avec le
pion 6 4 ça devient problématique pour
le noir parce que ça sa blonde la pause
on vient me semble empêcher bas dans ce
cas là je préfère les bons mer c'est
très loin d'être spécialiste ici très
loin donc ce que je dis n'a pas trop de
valeur mais pour moi c'est évident que
les bons souvenirs lors des trois taux à
des rouages de
ou peut-être moi je dors chez toi même
un moment donné mais bien sûr à chaque
fois il ya des finances tactique parce
que les noirs ils ont beaucoup quand
même
mais ils n'ont ils ont pas envie
d'essayer d'ouvrir les colonnes proche
du roi pour ta taquet
bien sûr oui bah justement on voit une
preuve je série devenir que cavagnan
dessin qui bloque la diagonale du fou c6
et donc il bloque alors l'accès de noir
occase jeu de agen 2-3 voilà quoi les
gens disent qu'il faut admettre que
driss roukhe est plus fort bon il n'est
pas plus fort je n'ai jamais dit que le
plus fort mais je pense j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui j'ai mieux
joué mais là maintenant
d'ailleurs il se fait dribbler il perd 1
billion and c'est ça le problème des
bureaux est en cours apparaît tu perds
un pion en fait c'est très stratégique
mais au moins deux femmes
il ya énormément d'articles mais dès la
pause ouais je sais pas s'il va réussir
cette fois ci tout bourbourg tour bouffe
qu'avocat vallée bout peut-être
d'ailleurs les noirs doivent pas échangé
le tour mais il va changer le ton est
monté à 3 séduit 3 décès trois des six
ok les besoins vont mettre le caveau les
surnoms ok 5 mauvaise gueule 5 très
mauvaise bull maroc est en cours au
mauvais comme rouages 12 je sens que ça
y est il faut vraiment que maxime gagne
celle là on n'a pas le droit de parler à
gagner ça là ok euro à 2,7 kovalev doro
abc curling hockey wade ci soit 3 5 mm f
ou g à en quoi le cavalier bleu données
cheik tioté 3 mais je pense que ça doit
se faire je pense qu'il est l'outil
lillois souhaite pouvoir échanger le
pion ces 4 contre l'un de ceux qui ont
doublé ou et séquestré roi aux cinq déjà
ok tu fais quoi
ok ok c'est bon tu sais si ce bo5 ok je
pense que c'est foutu
mais même temps
en fait enfin tu fais à trois je fais à
6 tu fais à 4 je fais à 5 même nom
qu'est ce qu'un bon ok on revient à 4
points pour talent ça m'étonnerait 6-max
vois je
cantini elle de jouer berlin jusqu'à la
fin du mois cheveux non mais c'était une
opportunité
ok plus à l'est il faut revenir à plus 3
je dirais ok est ce qu'il y aura beau 3
ou des 4 au troisième set des cadres est
3g 3g pourquoi pas un des quatre le camp
videlaine vlad dans l'ouvragé les jours
passent et que c'est l'un des 1000
points de vue simone williams toujours
j'ai toujours pensé que c'est carrément
l'art de gagner le plus de buts je mets
existants excusez moi ceux qui aiment
bien cette ouverture mais j'ai jamais
compris ce truc en catégorie 2 5 ce
normal en fait tireur fou cette idée si
vous voulez c'est quelque chose comme
ses trois petits rock des quatre enfants
un moment donné le loire ou poux qui lui
il a joué ici je pensais que le dessin
est différente jouets de cinq banques
oui mais ok en fait je regardais ça mais
ça fait longtemps que je regarde ok
maintenant moi je réfute de ruines
si cette équipe il serait fait dérober
sa répulsion
c'était t3 les d4 d se défoulent figure
il dis moi pourquoi est ce que tu m'as
aidé avec tournai d2 d4
ok maintenant vous réfugier et sur fuite
l'autre affirme détroit et au team
savoir un prêt d'ailleurs pour jouer de
trois tours dernier un coût 12 heures ok
juste pour presser les pendules peugeot
1,6
arrive tu as pas marre de l'inclusion
hafsi sakozy cavalli qui peut aller vers
f5
non mais pas ici oui enfin ça me fait
pas peur
ça me fait pas peur je n'a pas pointé
mais ok je pense qu à chaque fois ils
cherchent à trouver de quoi le coup les
plus agressifs aujourd'hui n'ont
peut-être à 4 à 4 bekkat makarios iii
qui c'est quatre cavaliers le 3 comme la
salle en fait si tu veux tu penses que
tu joues king sindian avec les
bourrelets soutiennent avec les bois
mais moi je joue l'espagne où est alors
mon ouverture et plus sain que le
triangle bancaires cb
pourquoi pas cavaler prend bas parce que
je pense que le cavalier ce 6e mieux que
le cow boys 2 je pense que les noirs
sont au milieu de jeunes je suis
complètement sûr faut ici d'ailleurs je
veux rappeler qu'ils ont la tour de
berne c'était un cours bizarre les noirs
sont nettement mieux aussi
le cavalier mauvais sur son dos mais ok
m voyelles c'est un très grand joueur
donc il va poser des problèmes mais s'il
ya quelqu'un qui me réussit c'est que le
noir regarde quand l'air 5 ou quand les
c5 c'est pas moins de six heures parce
que maintenant tu veux pas vraiment je
veux qu'on les secrets
peut-être que tu vas jouer torah c'est
un col et ses 5 ans elle est la terreur
sur rigole mais c'est pas une mauvaise
idée à lui que le pire ce même pas
cavaler ce2 le pire c'est le flambeau
deux ans eric les pièces sont embourbés
ok maintenant il faut donc comme je
pense qu'on peut pas faire genre f4 ce
que j'allais dire tourbe est un fou
c'est un f5 et tout envoyé non mais
maintenant comblé besoins sont très très
mal positionné m'a juste très très mal
il faut jouer les styles il faut je
pourrais jouer tour eiffel et 6 jets
pâques
mais parce qu'objectivement
positionnement c'est ce putsch ou
regarde les pièces blanches c'est
complètement foutue plumes
d'ailleurs il n'y a pas de coup
maintenant les futures - positionner le
maroc et que relèvent en cardiologie
calais à saint omer et il perd quand
même ok ok maintenant est ce que vous
voyez le juge d'instruction mais comme
je sens qu'avec les deux dames 3 plus
calmes et risma il aurait peut-être dû
faire d'alger sens au kek a volé à
quatre mois au québec à la 4-ème aussi
qu'on va laisser trois faubourgs et b
c'est ici dans madoff ou saint roch et
un gros bang
le st tiens d'horreur vlad a tjrs un
changement arcade enfin ok peut-être
comme sédhiou 959 tu peux expliquer
est-ce que les bois ou est-ce que les
besoins peuvent se moque il va alors si
tu enlèves le foot est un peu un
lecavalier fans qui avaient érigé un tu
pourras faire petit rock et si tu
enlèves le foot est un tu peux faire
grand cas d'accord ok compris ok le
début de la partie est très très
mélancolique
normalement les deux on était beaucoup
plus agressive d'al est parti aux
chèques normaux et ça commence très très
lentement
je comprends pas un grand chose 5
maintenant ok c'est possible ça va
devenir je prends un type 2 française
blizzard précise de cette lame
adaptateur un moment donné s'ils se font
soit sûr je suis comme les françaises
normal sauf que est-ce que l'on peut
traiter les françaises normalement comme
la dame sur abidjan support est à damas
huit va être complètement bloquée dans
ta française justement peut-être un gros
enfin peut-être à 5
quand la justice me paraît bizarre enfin
moi je réponds offres qui me fait jouer
sur la dame a un petit peu se faire
attaquer comme moi est ce que la dame /
a-1 peut-être attaque les sorties en 36
ou pro f 6 ha oui mais les bonbons les
bords vont pas prendre sur ok voilà il
nous faut suivre cette ligne auquel à
moi il a préparé le tir au hockey au
moins je compris ce qu'il ou elle devint
fou des cinq ans on peut pas à le
fouiller en d1
le coc classique dans lequel un frein
très tâche quatre comme s'assurera que
tu fais h5 tient pas mal d'ailleurs très
typiques comme un sacrifice pour les
françaises un prêtre atypique en fait
surface à rots km la marque honda les
françaises d'ailleurs une fois le cuir
noir est sûr c'est que les banques
veulent toujours faire faux bond à 5 ans
comme qui te rappellent la partie tout
que tu a commenté pour bliss prime sur
youtube com ans après leur envoyer le
compteur 1 et ouvrir le compteur grèce
chypre et oui quand il avait 6 et tout
ça ouais donc par contre tout est relié
noir vu pas perdre quand même entame
avec à 6 oui parce que je dommage mais
comment tu as vu cette vidéo
quand j'ai vu que les vidéos existent
mais je peux regarder les vidéos en
thomas scott aurait appris des trucs je
fais terme en fait sur a6 ouvert qu'à
rallier prendre cinq ans quatre ans cinq
dames prend des quatre pouliches dame
ces cinq échecs wabush trouver fou b4 et
je veux jouer sur le fait que tu as dame
rentre plus jamais en jeu
après dans ce sens qu'ils connaissent et
6 c'est ça le problème n ya pas de tête
non cadrée 5
ça marche pas elle ne plaît pas si il
est pas bien au score c'est pas c'est
pas le moment de ces désespérés non plus
quand même parce que peut-être il sait
quoi d'être beaucoup plus fort dans les
boules erp tête et donc ils voient pas
risqué trop non plus tu vois non mais si
c'est pas mal peut-être qu'il va
préparer cette idée 1,6
c'est pas mal de l'essence qui il est
clair que grichka vieux serre qui est
elle là bas est donc là au moins le
louvre nouveaux riches
par contre c'est pas trop bien dans le
sens qu il a donnée le cas je suis sous
fouet au cou france au four four two les
défenses françaises
mais peut-être maintenant on peut faire
puis on prend g7
moi je souhaite et food et 3 sur 4
j'aurais qu'il prend des quatre tours
joués sur l'offre comprise que plus bas
que terre avec très peu de terreau sur
info 2 3 je vais faire court je suis à l
apo à diane intéressant il veut utiliser
que la 4g 6ème libéré pour presser sur
ces deux avec vous je suis ma chambre je
commence à bien aimer great choquant
fait en gros ils jouent cette ce match
carrément de les styles
quand elle avait l'âge de 18 ans
comme quoi très romantique d'ailleurs sa
façon de jouer sous main le ça
m'étonnerait pas si à un moment donné
leurs photos tous et d'autre on se doit
de trouver mais d'ailleurs le prochain
tour si le joueur se qualifie ce sera
normalement contre 40 scènes et cie
gritche joue comme ça il peut même
l'éliminer tu sais que même que carl
scène n'a jamais perdu un match de
speech nations can ship elle n'a jamais
gagné un match avec moins de quatre ou
cinq points d'écart
parce qu'à chaque fois c'était des
boucheries contre absolument tout le
monde tient là il pourrait se passer un
truc marrant imagine genre ok pour rire
un genre fou prend 1,4 comprend 1 4
cavaliers e3 plus on prend 1,3 à te dire
qu'elle est bien cadré pull et ouais
c'est assez rare cm je comprendre le
problème de riche maintenant il pense
que peut-être elle est en train de jouer
à main d'oeuvre y est
lorsque tu sens que tu joues un seul
corps il est toujours très très calme à
dire tu as toujours peur de dodo merdes
est ton pittsburgh
ouais et du coup tu joues moins pratiqué
tu veux jouer
c'est ça le problème par contre
l'envoûtement il n menace horrible avec
e3 où il s'en va toucher le tour aux
agents locaux venaient de deux mêmes
voyez le sait les ouvriers ont d'abord
il pose des problèmes tactiques tout de
suite
inquiet il veut faire dame prend 1,6
dame j'ai quatre échecs et cavalier e 4
pour tous sauvés par exemple donc mais
peut-être un coup à la con construite
même si le tabac d'un rire soutient les
finales mais pions sont tellement génial
que j'ignore qui ose tout même changé
les les dom je sais pas je sais pas mais
je pense que quand même il prend en
compte qu il en reste pas trop trop trop
de partis avant la fin de cette heure il
s'est dit les finales et secure mais je
sais pas si les raisons tient assez gris
chaud qui joue avec les bois ah merde
jamais à mais le duo les toits non mais
c'est parce que ça a tourné les couleurs
depuis tout à l'heure en fait à personne
nous a dirigés alors ben je sais pas
j'ai pas regardé c'est trop passionné
dans ce cas là c'est moi qui a joué
qu'est en train de
on sait pas du tout rendu causes
auxquelles au final les femelles depuis
tout à l'heure est devenu peut-être un
peu moins cool pour les noirs à cause de
cavaler sur ces cinq lots blessures et
six oui mais les noirs ils ont tous un
point point pour un tuyau
sauf que les personnes que chalmé par le
four f2 maintenant donc je suis tout
lâche et ç'a été bizarre quand même
parce que il est clair qu après tour je
suis tu veux pas échangé beaucoup air
sur m6 que je pense que ce match va
gagner ce partir comment copions du coup
en fait c'est elle qui jouait dans le
style de la nouvelle devise à la roue et
ouais ok c'est chose que rossi à me
faire mal guidé par le haut comme à dire
par les styles de griche commencé moi je
vous aime non mais c'est aussi parce
qu'ils ont arrêté de changer de couleur
pour le 960 parce qu'ils veulent avoir
bouffé sur le cas ils pourraient
pourquoi sur caterino parfois j'ai pas
compris qu'ils papa il ya des deux os 2
et et alors ils devraient pour fouiller
souvent passer une bonne nouvelle c'est
est max y avait les noirs parce que ça
ça veut dire qu'on revient
ok ça fait quoi + 4 + cats et maintenant
les les boulettes oui tiens ça chauffe
tiens ça chauffe ok je vais tourner près
vide à tout à l'heure nous sommes tout
de suite car je met un petit lien
n'oubliez pas de partager ces choses +4
les mecs on peut encore le faire
quatre points d'écart c'est pas grand
chose et ça peut se tenir
ça peut se tenir du coup je vais je vais
remettre un petit lien pour que vous
partagiez sur les réseaux sociaux si
vous avez facebook ou quoi et tout peut
encore arriver là quatre points c'est
rien c'est rien du tout même on peut
revenir
on y croit
j'aime être le lien vous puissiez
partager
disons qu'il va rester plus que plus que
quelques plus que 30 minutes 30 minutes
s'est déjà préparé le truc
faudra tenter un truc
on va tenter un truc pour les bullet on
aura un tout petit peu de décalage sur
les images me manque pour à les avoir
je vais juste les récupérer sur internet
et comme ça on pourra les avoir je vais
m l'aqim de l'ordi voir ce que ça donne
les demain soir n'oubliez pas il y aura
le match entre entre car iachini
nepomniachi donc partager un maximum 1
le match le match aujourd'hui déjà
on j'ai récupéré les caméras ils auront
un léger décalage mais ce sera déjà ça
qui on va tenter
si on peut
oco you ça me paraît un peu dur
récupérer les images temps on va pas
rester avant les avants les bullet et
maxime a l'air pas mal sur le sur la
caméra hiver d'être chaud ça commence sa
partie ralala hockey boule est
d'habitude que marche je cavale hebdo
dans cette position je pense dans votre
foi je pense pas qu'il ait jamais fait
ok moi je parle de la théorie mais
peut-être que moi je les terrorise voix
avoir pas beaucoup d'importance
non mais là de toute façon vu la laddh
oui oui bien sûr c'est surtout la
rapidité et les tactiques les tactiques
les rapidité et parfois un peu stratégie
mais pas autant que ça je comprends je
comprends ok pas une surprise et un mac
joue plus vite et il est dominant plus
autant pas autant que ça un cours moyen
pour moi vous séparer c'est presque jeu
plus rapide sauf que je suis pas
impressionné par son père et moi comment
ils jouent ça parce que je retiens de
rentrer foie gras vraiment
impressionnant ok les noirs doivent être
un petit peu mieux je suppose
on ne sait pas quel point ce coup-ci ce
que voulait à 400 cadres sont bien sûr
mais 3000 parce que les banques doivent
vraiment faire pour que les conséquences
soient pas trop graves et qui viennent
parce qu'il faut aussi cécile touba car
les deux faut trouver le coup après
pollution sans valse championship un
petit peu mieux aux tendeurs juste en
train de mettre le score vlad sur
l'écran mais tu suis les parties je suis
la partie de loin là pour le mans
ok mes amis riches que mieux il ya un
pion de plus
mais justement avec ces deux derniers
couvrent 85 e max cherche à troubler les
je sais pas s'il va réussir
il a beau et il a réussi deux boîtiers
le fou noir mais il a besoin de moi m6
se situe donc je suppose que voulez-vous
deux camps les sécateurs et cool oui
tour bouge que les c4 ok les noirs sont
gagnants mais je sais pas qu'est ce qui
va nous arriver
ok les bons ne sont pas trop bien
maintenant je suppose qu'ils font de 5,1
elle devrait plus beaucoup avec eux le
connaît aussi
ok d'ailleurs c'est très surpris qu'il y
aurait chaque jour cette partie plus
rapide que son adversaire car les cinq
ça fait 2e qui ont de plus et appelés
près de sa position nous toujours très
blanc devait donc il faut à max il faut
absolument qu il trouve quand même passé
des problèmes non les parricides plus
simple de nouveaux pauvres riches où il
ya vu ça ça fait beaucoup lablad ça fait
beaucoup et peut-être ça a été une des
parties décisives sipa les décisions ok
de nouveaux riches au cou et ses 2 e
oui faire maths dans les siciliens on va
voir s'il va réussir
ok ça cette variante avec damas cinq
bien sûr c'est une variante comment dire
c'est une variante favorite quoi de dôme
de sébastien mazet l'entraîneur de
l'équipe de france n'est donc pas une
surprise que mercy mois ci mis à jouer
eux aussi c'est plus entre r l'équipe de
france c'est lydie maintenant ok mais là
un des entraîneurs à l'hérault quelques
envois maintenant son heure plus tôt ok
plutôt joueur mais pas d'un très très
longtemps à l'intérieur de l'équipe ou
et surtout un grand pot de toute
l'équipe donc normal que moi que tout
sera ok riche de toute évidence n'a pas
été surpris à tient dans le dos bien sûr
ça se pratique au hockey
il a commencé sa très agressivement
moins une fois il était plus trop sur ok
il propose de changer les dangers de
toutes façons de la dir-est 26 minutes
en gros il ya une dizaine de parties à
jouer ce qui a une secondes par coup une
dizaine
ouais moi aussi c'est une dizaine tout
est passible en cours ok l'écart est
grand mais tout est possible et encore
parce que douze 12 c'est beaucoup et
vous savez mes amis j'ai une très grosse
expérience de jeu les blitz un brise
très souvent ça va parler voit guère
bouger très très bien d'un coup vous
comprenez plus rien ne bouge ou et moi
donc tout est possible
moi perso je suis akio ça va pas changer
mais non moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
max il a raté un peu des opportunités à
un moment donné à 3 + 2 pour recoller
oui mais s'il reste et ça c'est aussi
parce que l'autre a pas moins de
résister c'est vrai mais du coup le
scénario du match si tu veux il est
vraiment en faveur de grisou sauf que je
dois dire que j'ai pas trop aimé les
dernières opérations de riches où je
pense que les noirs doivent être mieux
sais pas quel point les doigts doivent
terminer je suppose tiens eux a
maintenant bien sûr une fois les
structures des pions des bois n'est pas
bon donc c'est max qui cherchent de
l'échangé d'arras et de ckoi lisez
surtout ceux dont il veut faire d'alger
cinq danseuses d'un jeu 5 bat dans tous
les cas c'est sacré
puis [ __ ] les dents sur m6 où et
comment et quoi d'autre juste à kaya
touristiquement cette recette a marché
il devrait jouer des recettes auxquelles
et des attaques auxquelles peut pas
jouer
ok là maintenant il voit le matériel la
tour sur m6 ou moins ça marche bien
parce que tout a défendu rick est pas
bien joué par les choux que bientôt il
va beaucoup mieux mais il est d'ailleurs
géré moi je joue il va essayer de jouer
le plus longtemps possible à 2 août
façon je comprends
t'es ok plus ou moins ridicule mon bon
ok pas voisine de 5 à la rando accueil
ils bouclent dame ok les cures à 8 à gué
certains faisant battre tous ok ok il a
party associera les petits la pire
partie de quelque chose dans le monde
comme la laci mv ali gagne on revient à
trois points et tu va sentir le souffle
revenir sur toi ben ouais c'est pas la
dernière partie des gens m'a pas plu du
tout comme je vous ai dit au qatar c'est
l'un des principaux conte au qatar jouer
avant parce que je suis donc sûr h3
rauque et bah je sais pas je pense qu'on
peut faire tout ce que tu veux à 104,6
que les deux sets
moi j'aurais fait à chaque fois ok si f3
peut-être ryad des dommages a essayé
trois fous de 5e jeu 5 peut-être une
fois sacrifié une pièce tiens j'ai géré
de mes pièces alors je déteste le fou
sûr je suis comme je suis conscient mac
c'est pas ma tête à 4 maintenant on veut
faire à saintes
ok maintenant c'est clair voici jour
joue à 5 heures mais il faut ouvrir la
pause à tout prix à chaque jeu 51 7
après six mois à tout prix quoi parce
que c'est intolérable et il faut que mon
nom j'ai mis en cause ont pas comment
justement ok peut-être un jeu comme
angie cinq mouvements un moment donné il
va sacrifier le pion avec doussain je
suppose
bientôt d'heure ok corral et je sens à
réfléchir ni roi ni de tranquille proche
d'eux et puis tu réfléchir
pas mal pas mal ça c'est pas mal et
prépare la case
regard maxime il joue vite là ouais
j'aime pas comment que les shojo ça va
libérer 15 4 ça par contre c'est pas sûr
que la véraison parce que la mode a eu 4
4 cavaliers 3 oui d'abord un tour ou
vent ça et après que choko 4 4 les x et
d'ailleurs tu peux choisir et qu'il me
manque une foule retient
allez allez kasparov ou gligoric les
deux on fait ça mille fois oui tiens
cette fois ci c'est gris chaud qui fait
l'audio crédit d'ailleurs j'aime bien le
noir jour dans le noir mais pourquoi pas
que les quatre corps les g3 mc et les
duos ça c'est vrai que c'est un peu
soupçonnant peut-être tout en annonçant
que tous trois être éminemment wassim
même ne devrait croître et menace en
russie
daems et dante lam de 8 est attendu dans
les noix sont à ma voisine buffalo 2
c'est pas mal aussi des combats
s'étaient pas il a disparu la tour ah
oui ok + 5
peut-être c'est ça la partie décisive
bon pas en cours et l'adresse peut-être
d'y jouer je te dire ne restent pas dit
si l'on raisonne 7,8
ok la socri tieger
tiens même rôle que jouent les
françaises et 500 chevaux non mais
auquel il a raté trop de chances dans ce
match mais déjà je pense point qu'ils
ont
il la connaît assez bien parce que au
lieu de [ __ ] de ce que je voulais
voler à 5,12 suite justement pour éviter
de quoi normalement les noirs les spas
obame de jeu pourquoi parce que ok c'est
fantastique
tiens tu sais y'a un truc qui va te
choquer mais moi j'étais au courant
c'est quel lien peut jouer là j'ai un
peu étudié la française et donc tu fait
cavalier à 50
et généralement tu fais un plan avec le
cavalier qui revient vers sète ses huit
baies 6 pour faire x 4 oui oui bien sûr
je sais c'est le point principal fond de
scène que valeo cette cavale et ses huit
que voulait briller c'est après x 4 j'ai
voulu apprendre quelque chose mais j'ai
pas réussi
je pense que tu peux à un moment donné
mais aujourd'hui ok lamotte now t il a
perdu son avantage le chou tout ce qu'il
veut un jour pour le oui
c'est donc sur le rêve de ma télé noir
soit sûr je sais soit sur le but here we
mais sinon objectivement elle joue mal
ça parce que les pucerons
ça c'est évident ok oui ok tout ce qu'il
veut c'est que les jeux 5e le 4ème à son
gré tout pour faire ma quote merde je
tire ma mauvaise qu'il faut d'ailleurs
il joue aussi mon retard et joue ça
aussi mauvais comme elle est partie
précédente avec les bois qu'il a juste
plus d'attaqué va voir à 5 à 4 à 3 et
d'ailleurs exactement le même scénario
les deux pions sous double d'ivoire nos
yeux quoi de voir les yeux de
spectateurs quoi je sais pas pourquoi
les gens d'ici a aucun enjeu à cette
compétition ils sont complètement fous
en fait pourquoi qu'elle a occasionnés
pas ils disent que c'est une condition
ne sert à rien mais en fait il ya un
titre en jeu quand même bon mais a je
pense qu'on peut difficilement à dire ça
dans un tournoi où tous les meilleurs
joueurs d'elie jour tient bon sang
qu'est-ce qu'il n'a pas oublié dans buzz
sur internet
3 je pense et carrier bouger dames 6 3
oui madame 3g de trucs comme dom
vayssette
mais n'oublie pas c'est moi qui a le
plus haut sur six pour toi ô bô 5 ou
évoquer bressan c'était trop bon quel
que soit on peut dire qu'il voulait
louis pas mal de fois il a fait des
fautes en force et et cette fois ci ce
qui est bien c'est que même si que je
vois perdre ça ça va prendre beaucoup de
mais cette partie c'est dû au mauvais
niveau je dois vous avouer je pense
qu'un mode deux joueurs m'excuse
m'excuseront mais cette fois ci c'était
une partie pas aussi intéressant qu'il
revend ok bien sûr les bonnes sont pour
moi violent que j'aie hockey car les
bosses à sa part est de faire une
proposition de news parce que comment tu
peux perdre ça ok nul une partie de moi
à tient jusqu'au boutisme ok mais je ne
sais pas comment ça peut se faire mais
là je pense qu est la fois une faute
mars basque parce que même s'ils gagnent
ça ça va prendre du temps oui non enfin
s'ils gagnent toujours intéressant en
fait à aucune affiche le plus haut sur
des sites ben quoi ça je peux te les
sourires
tu peux le pire verdoyant prévoit genou
droit jeudi les baisses mais c'est les
noirs qui doit prouver
ok mais c'est nulle part répétition
week-end oui ça c'était bien sûr une
très grosse chance pour mes cheveux
non mais il reste à peu près cinq six
parties avec le 960 peut-être cette
image ou vite mais il reste à cinq
points de retard
ah tiens mais est ce qu elle voit de
nouveau répété tout du coup non et leurs
fouets ça c'est désespérant pour nous on
est français là on s'attendait pas du
tout à ça même toit avant le match
c'était pas très confiant en oui moi je
fais pas tout dit mais est ce que tu vas
dire tout quoi non jamais plutôt terrain
jour mais pas aujourd'hui sociaux et
jetez pas tout dit dira jamais tout mais
du coup la grosse rencontre ce sera
contre 40 cents c'est un gros choc mais
je pense que great food devra hausser
son niveau de jeu car il ya cet oubli je
pense que contre bâle et il faut gagner
samax ah les un baroud d'honneur
ok ça va pas durer longtemps le russie
sous m ok ok mais la fatigue ok j'ai me
va pas abandonner parce qu'il veut faire
tourner la pendule tu m'a expliqué déjà
en fait j'aurais oublié ça m a bien fait
de m'expliquer la stratégie pour doper
les moyens mais jusqu'à quel point tu
fais tourner parce que si ces genres
complètement perdant est ce que ces
manques de respect ou tu continues à
faire un nom qui claque des dents
tellement dans un tel match et
rocamadour esprits
tu fais tu fais comme tu veux ou disons
qu'ici c'est un manque de respect mais
ok mais comment dire mais ça se comprend
c'est la stratégie quoi ça se comprend
tout le monde comprend tu peux te faire
pardonner par tobias l'astuce hockey des
genres aller jusqu'à roi-dame contre
dame se serait trop tout maintenant 3
dawn est bien sûr
ouais et qui sait peut-être dernière
fois le du compte cette crainte c'est
qu'on sait exactement ce qu'il va te
manquer ou non c'est sûr mais ok
peut-être que là quelque part ça
commence à tout match
bon ok ok comme tous les modèles
ok mais ça je peux pas te bouffe
non mais accorde non appel le paddy
vides abandonnées qua non messieurs
seraient pas sûr qu'il faut c'est pas
partout quoi rime a décidé de bloquer
ses trop nombreux qui tu peux pas faire
ça dit le haut après l'armée s'il attend
28 secondes c'est too much non ok ça
c'est trop vous avez le texte trop
non ça c'est too much je veux que tout
le tchad cif qua non mais ok et le pire
c'est qu'il va faire voir encore pour
[Musique]
et les profs et d'ailleurs non mais ok
ça c'était too much
ok tiens qu'est ce qui n'a pas laissé
contre 4,1 pour qu'ils soient punis pour
avoir fait ça dans une zone d'un moine
de plus beau que le nôtre qui vivent ça
c'était trop vlad
j'espère que tu lui diras quand même non
jamais c'était trop non mais piégeux
jusqu'au matt déjà c'était beaucoup mais
si tu laisses tourner la pendule
l'espère avant laisse tourner avant mais
là s'accumulent trop quand même
ok
peu importe maintenant revenons sur le
papier jamais on reviendra sur les
parties bhl il met masse comme beckett
damphousse rambert et d'approuver 5
parce que faut boire mais quand les
secours arrivent donc mais le cavaliere
avait toujours susceptible hockey j'aime
bien les noirs un feuilleton j'aime bien
le noir mais ok je peux pas dire que les
noirs sont mieux non plus ok égale égale
aussi peut-être hkd tout autant propres
idées retour au vent maintien il veut
des pratiques à même moi ici il veut te
pratique pour une banque pourquoi elle
n'a pas compris sur des cintres ou si je
comprends pas terminé le temps mais
maintenant elle peut prendre parce que
les noirs peut pas reprendre avec le
plomb c'est donc le noir doivent
reprendre euh ok comme ça ça peut se
faire aussi
ok bien sûr repenser la position d'un
secours pour les bons avec les dés
compréhensible pour tout le monde de
changer le tout comme les 2 2 tab 6 pas
mal ces cadres nient tout reprendre à
pardon au caire maintenant il va il
menace que vous les deux exactement le
moment pour ce cadre parce que le roi
noir que de terrain tous soupçons en
avant qui ont il est arrivé jusqu'à six
semaines le noyau à loire doit se cacher
sur m6 qui peut pas dans quoi
tobos être éliminé les nettement mieux
de la mort cet abandon
ah tiens c'est la fatigue c'est l'effet
dit tu vois donc pas donné les résultats
ce qui se passe avant celle à ces six
jeunes et pire les parties d'avant sa
fatigue est élevé voilà maintenant
terminée d'ailleurs je suis d'accord
avec un commentaire de vent et les
organisateurs devraient définir en
nombre de parties je suis assez d'accord
en fait toi tu comprends mieux
comme je sais pas tu comprends mieux tu
a commenté autant de déjà moi beaucoup
moins donc juste sais pas peut-être oui
plus que je sais pas
non en fait moi je voudrais que ce soit
un système de sept ans fait moins en
revanche c'est toi qui m'as dit que tu
adores justement le système que non mais
j'adore le fait que ça joue pendant
longtemps et c'est du blitz sa j'adore
oui mais je pense c'est possible
d'améliorer le forme en faisant 17 h
ok mais la fatigue et la fatigue est
terrible pour les deux relégables les
trois dernières parties c'est là c'est
vraiment pas n'importe quoi moi ok bon
après on en parle ça a été du très haut
niveau en fait donc je peux pas les
réponses mais invoquer le truc c'est que
great je sache qu'un kefu g4 et abandon
mais le truc c'est qu'il va pas
abandonner
non il faut pas montrer
il nous a montré que nous tous qui ne
voient pas ok mais comme souvent
j'ai dit on peut pas critiquer les
jambes
vous vous changez le système juste
l'expression célèbre d'eau là samedi et
comme l'a dit un moment demain ceux qui
critiquent les grands maux est pour les
nuls de salon ne comprennent pas qu
est-ce que c'est un tour - mais c'est
juste je comprends le truc quoi mais
jouer jusqu'au dernier coup et faire
tiquer la pendule et si tu vois pas le
fou rire et à cause de toi tu vas perdre
non mais juste il pourrait y avoir un
hockey à certains sports où ça existe
comme au rugby ou tuent tous les
arbitres ils ont le droit d de d'arbitré
l'esprit de la règle en fait et du coup
sinon juste envie de te dégager auquel
elle a par contre si fait c'est un
cavalier c'est comme tout match
non mais pour éviter m'attendait je
verrai pas trouvé les des noms ok mais
ça t'évite de faire le pré m'ouvre des
trois c1 dans ces cas-là malin waziérois
saint-damien mater quand même si la
chambre et move tu gagnes oui je sais
mais géré par là le mec a peut-être fait
d'un match entre mouz et du coup ci fait
d'un machin qui soit encore roy b2 quoi
vue hockey dont toute évidence macready
céder d'autres tester toutes les
ouvertures contre 4 go
alors il a décidé de jouer la
scandinavie a compris que c'était la
meilleure ouverture et je pense que je
comme moi qui ai 6,6 grand roque damage
500 c'est quoi sauf que ici il peut pas
faire sans couette
trsb intéressante urique moi je vais
parce que j'ai pas que ça ait sa part
est d'être très pressés parce que les
deux font très pressés parce que les
dauphins je préfère les bois ouais je
sais pas est ce que c'est beaucoup mais
collé des deux jours de cavale et bo3 et
ma chambre tu as ukulélé qui dit j'ai vu
presque tous les speechs nation qu'un
type j'ai jamais vu un autre faire ça en
eau
c'est la première fois quoi mais ce sera
peut-être pas la dernière je pense que
les autres vont s'inspirer en fait ouais
ils ont raison et en a un autre qui
écrit d'ailleurs en russe quoimaligne
keep les disques carrément cyrillique
le public n'est pas content vlad pardon
le public français n'est pas content il
coûte si le public français aurait été
contente de cela saurait pas été les
publics français quoi donc comme moyen
qu'est-ce que je le comprends si j'étais
de l'autre côté de la brigade de
l'église le thème les mêmes choses ou
non mais je pense pareil ça décide de
match de toute façon parce que ok ça a
peut-être enlever une partie mais en
fait de toute façon ça aurait pas changé
l'issue du truc n'oublions pas juste les
agents sont importants les ajouts sont
importants parce que c'est pas mal
principal c'est tout ce qu'ils ont dit
que c'était un match d'amusement avec sa
servent à rien face si les mecs sont ils
une chose un peu dire sur moi c'est pas
du tout un match et d'amusement ça c'est
sûr que vous voulez sur les samoa ce
trait principal point presse kyodo très
bon jour jours mais deux parmi le plus
fort de l'ecofin serait plus qu il ya
des gens qui disent que c'est ton
influence qui lui a fait faire ça
ok fei fei a commencé à insulter le
commentateur énorme qu'emi semaine pas
nul va jouer ça pendant des heures par
mais ok on a compris son but mais ça
peut se retourner contre lui parce que
les autres feront pareil qu elles le
font le match est fini il reste trois
minutes 4 points d'écart
il va rester deux parties dis moi
d'ailleurs compteur qui voit jouer son
match parfait contre sceaux je crois de
mémoire
là tout est clair qu'avec fabien on
pense que c'est 95%
ouais quand ça veut je veux pas vos
compteurs dire quelque chose comme ça en
fait on comprends pas vraiment comment
sophie gagnon
ok sauf si l'autre est malade par
exemple tiens mais ce qu' il va se payer
le luxe de jouer la finale avec tours 5
en donnant un pion aux caisses peut
faire tous rêvent 4 allée nulle
pourquoi pour jouer plus de coups bas
à un moment donné vers la corde mais bon
ok mais elle aurait pu être plus
technique laisser tourner sa pendule
vers le pas à économiser encore 50
secondes
il a laissé la règle des 50 coups ok h44
toujours intéressant de voir une partie
qui commence comme ça mais je pense que
maxime est très énervé
va reste une minute made
mathématiquement c'est fini complètement
finie et c'est quoi le score plus que
tout autre le 5 jeux + 4 de toute façon
il y aura une partie de 960 après dans
tous les cas mais le truc c'est que
maxime peu marqué que deux points
maintenant c'est juste fini d'accord
tiens il a réussi de magouilles et de
riches ou quand même vécu trois
écolières 14 hockey en fait serment à
moins que ce que je pensais
vous reconnaissez pas faire du tour
auquel doit à terme et bien sûr ils ont
te disent de ne pas oublier le car
malade
écoutez il ya peu de gens qui
connaissent aussi bien l'histoire et ce
qu'ils aiment c'est sans moi p moi mon
ouïe et à leekens a aussi bien que je le
coup mais quoi je peux dire que
clairement aux chais que l'agencé points
je ne sais pas jamais on te pardonnera
sommes très énervé n'arriveront qu'à
visiter sans rien changer de façon qui
tu préfères et si les bois le noir blanc
sans aucun doute mettriez sculpteurs
sont fatigués et en colère parce que au
lieu de ses katas bien sûr tour suite et
après défaut de crack mais les doses
sont fatigués à bloc à bloc
c'était long et difficile qu'un match
mais je suis convaincu que si griffioen
joue comme ça contre carl ça se sera
passé
bon voyons donc
voyons donc que le truc c'est que maxime
a raté pas mal de chance et je pense que
le score contre carl scène en bullet
aurait été un peu plus désespérant pour
great choqué et il finit que à +4
finalement au bon mais le déjà ce qui
aurait imploré ce ratio est il est au
courant
comment une fois peut-être guerre sainte
dans les boulettes parce qu'il a vu au
ca de jeu parce qu'avant il pouvait pas
sans moi je n'ai à quel point mais
plutôt fois juste pour vous passez moi
je motive et donc comment dire quand tu
es pro vigne ou quand même tenir
informés n'est ce pas logique
ouais donc parce que c'était un choc en
fait bien sûr si c'était si c'était ma
caméra c'est ce même point surprise mais
c'est un choc
quel poids mais les terribles la routine
et même peut-être plus fort que da
camera en fait mais il n'a pas montré sa
contre la camorra mais il est vrai nom
mais le match était déjà finie en fait
il a dominé au début des bullet et quand
le match était gagné nakamura est
remonté et a même gagné le truc de
bullet
mais je veux dire par là que si ça
n'avait pas été le cas
ok nioulé donc oui la dernière bulle est
alors cette fois-ci bizarrement les rois
sont leurs pauses sont sur leur pause
normes aux normes à l'om ward un mois de
déjà vu avec fabien dans un autre
960 c'était une très mauvaise idée fait
g4 ici juste est fou c'est 4 vous foutez
trois fosses et 85e j'ai pas compris
pourquoi cow boys boys berne ses singles
donc grille tout cas les blancs à très
chic et les bons à attends je mens pas
compris comment quelqu'un veut gagner un
pion quoi pion à deux tout à l'heure à
ok ça a été je mens pas compris comment
elle accueille un pionner de vieux
complètement gaga ou chimie pour moi y
mêle mois plus 3 oui puisque cette
partie va gagner ok s'il n'avait pas
fait le truc salle des dd comme on
appelle du temps et il y aurait eu
encore fait deux parties donc au final
tu vas aller et ça aurait été plus y
jouer et +11 peut-être le suivre mais
mon peut-être que ça fait tilt et maxime
aussi le fait qu'il prenne son temps
comme ça bah bien sûr disons que tant
que tu peux utiliser quoi que ce soit
c'est ce qu'ont les gens disent bon
ouais et est ce que le gras matar avril
à raison de proposer news le bousculait
te foutyou pas oui il a raison parce que
si tu acceptes qu'il se saurait si tu
acceptes pas ça met la pression
tiens les chansons de vigneault moins
cohérent parce que parce que quand même
le aux cavaliers visé chiche et non mais
après moi j'aurais fait pareil que gris
tout cas je te rassure
j'aurais fait la même chose en fait sa
ba voila quoi au moins que la boue non
mais c'est sûr mais je le dis souvent
dans les scream quand les mecs me font
tomber ou quoi je suis très mécontent
mais en fait je fais exactement pareil
non mais en fait le problème aussi c'est
que lorsque aller à la belle époque j'ai
un cours jouer sur l'essai c'est ok
parfois je pensais que j'aurais pas
ferait un truc celle que je faisais de
fouet
et mais comment dire mais quand à la
fois une deux trois quatre cinq fois n'y
a même un jeu qui est sorti comme ça
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas longtemps
ouais ou en fait à genre quatre profils
psychologiques
les mecs qui s'adaptent les mecs qui
font toujours salle les mecs qui font
toujours propre et un quatrième type en
fait je me rappelle plus est en fait la
mémoire là le machin de l'histoire c'est
que ce qu'ils sont
qui font comme les autres gagnent
toujours mais le hic c'est que comme
ceux qui gagnent en premier c'est ceux
qui sont sales donc les mecs qui font
comme les autres deviennent salle aussi
en fait c'est la morale du jeu et donc
les seuls qui perd vraiment instructions
toujours sympa ok je comprends ce que tu
veux vraiment ce que je veux dire et en
fait la morale du jeu c'est que tout le
monde devient sale par la force des
choses parce que les meilleurs c'est ce
qu'ils s'adaptent et comme les deuxièmes
meilleures c'est ceux qui sont sales
tout le temps du coup tu vois ce que tu
pourrais trouver la vidéo si tu veux ok
bon dans tous les cas c'est terminé
c'est moche
exactement c'est sur la chaîne de
squeeze comme lady comme nicollin je
tiens à rappeler à tous ceux qui
critiquent les décisions de griche uk
aujourd'hui il a joué beaucoup mieux et
si ça vous pourrez pas voir c'est à vous
d'y céder
qu'est ce que vous pouvez non mais ils
font exactement pareil au rugby par
exemple qui regardent souvent du rugby
quand une équipe à dix points de plus
bas tout d'un coup les mecs sont blessés
ou mettre énormément de temps pour aller
jouer une touche quand il marche très
lentement vers la touche et qui est mené
au score bailly pourquoi il court vers
le ballon et il joue vite mais c'est
toujours comme ça et les commentateurs
il y souvent que si tu veux pas que ça
arrive pas il faut mener au score en
fait c'est tout enfin c'est ce que j'ai
fait et si on n'avait pas voulu que ça
arrive bas ainsi mvl avait trois points
de plus bas inscrits chocolat jamais
fait ça donc
la morale de l'histoire c'était le tout
premier jeu parce qu à la fin du compte
le résultat du match d'aujourd'hui a été
correct oui ça change donc et je suis
moi même agréable et moi surpris par
comme ailleurs pas la façon par exemple
juste rappelons nous de cette partie
d'un lot à grains prix non oui c'était
magnifique dont 24 à la fin oui donc
après le match il yad'autres bbc qui a
été gagné brillamment avoir envoyé
riches ou cailloux sa revanche donc
voyons de la fuite
l'histoire continue quoi mais pour ma
nico et puis que je confonds le rugby et
le foot je regarde énormément de rugby
et ça arrive assez souvent rugby que les
équipes se dépêche pas pour jouer les
touches ou les mails et quand elle mène
au score
ça arrive même très souvent ou par
exemple ils n'ont plus qu'à mettre le
ballon en touche pour gagner à la fin du
temps évidemment il mettre le ballon en
touche ils vont pas garder le ballon sur
le terrain c'est de mettre un effet un
essai donc du coup
donc voila mais c'est juste des règles
du jeu qui sont comme sa fin juste pour
dire quoi mais bon pendant le match on
avait le droit d'être énervé quand même
bon ben j'ai eu mon brevet sur d'autres
chansons que vous êtes les fois là
qu'est ce que je comprends moi moi je
t'ai pas d'un très longtemps enfants
nadeau foot moi tu n'as fans à dos d'un
truc mais qu'est ce que je vous que je
comprends vos réactions bah vous n'êtes
pas un robot de recherche ou quoi
évidemment mais bon après c'est et
sports et voilà il a utilisé les règles
du jeu il a eu raison est une façon sans
rien changer donc on peut pas se
plaindre
en revanche la ve dans un match
précédent il ya un truc qui l'a même
embêter plus mais bon c'est la règle
aussi ses aronian il a été déconnecté
d'internet pendant cinq minutes ça ok
bon c'est la règle et tout ça et c'est
normal que ça a été fait comme ça mais
ça me faisait plus mal au coeur pour
aronian parce qu'il a perdu un point
près en fait ouais ouais je me repose je
me rappellerai voyez donc ok en gros il
ya pas mal de choses qu'ils peuvent
améliorer pour la déconnexion cinq
minutes c'est peut-être un peu pour le
tournoi déjà préféré 2.2 jeand'heur ils
peuvent encore améliorer les règles ils
peuvent encore améliorer je pense qu'un
système de 7 ce serait plus marrant
parce que ça ferait comme au tennis
c'est à dire que tu vas au tennis même
si tu gagnes de 7 0 et 5 2 ou 3
27 qui peut encore perdre qu'est ce que
je veux dire tout peut toujours arriver
donc ça finit toujours par quelque chose
alors que là les dernières parties
audiences avec éric lucas va gagner le
match
moyer la ville a pris d'autres trop de
points d'avantagé avoir les boules elle
est donc ben on se donne rendez vous
demain pour le match de quarts yakine
contre
nevo est normalement jusqu'au montrer
avec fabien 17 kg pas de favori ça va
être un beau à cette fois-ci peut-être
je veux vous suivrez écouter mes amis ça
a été toujours un plaisir pour moi de
commenter ça pour vous et à bientôt
alors 5e match goodbye au yoyo